[Music]
three two one action it's off the record
we're parently we do whatever we want no
no no we talked about whatever this is
her segment so you could do what you
want it was a jab and look I've been
trying to get them to fill them for
about 30 minutes now I was not but
before we get into that we have a word
from our sponsor which is skills shared
thank you very much skill share he'll
share is an online learning community
with thousands of classes covering
dozens of creative and entrepreneurial
skills I love learning me too
Premium Membership gives you unlimited
access so you can join the classes in
communities that are just right for you
so if you're just curious or you want to
increase your creativity or if you want
to move up in your job world in your
career skill sure is the perfect place
to keep you learning and thriving and
they have super informative classes
about things like film and video music
production animation and much more and
there's even a new really interesting
one where you can make your videos look
more cinematic with lighting subject
placement all the stuff that you need to
make good you it really makes a big
difference we got to upgrade our film
skills at skill share and skill share is
also incredibly affordable especially
when compared to pricey in-person
classes and workshops an annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month
Wow because Skillshare is sponsoring
this video you can sign up with the link
in the description box below and get a 2
month free trial baby amazing head over
to sk l dot s H slash roosterteeth to
get a two month free trial Thank You
Skillshare Thank You Skillshare guys
welcome back to off-the-record today i'm
bose your substitute teacher i'm kind of
like one of those teachers it just
wheels in the TV you know
we yeah we kind of go with it and I also
have a co-host today Sam Michael I had a
Spanish teacher in high school yeah and
I think she gave up on us because we
were so bad we washed matrix in English
[Music]
massacres or Oh in [ __ ] English for
three months straight what if she was
depressed she's a really good friend
shout-out miss Romano
she moved no she was great oh yes did
you learn Spanish uh I should know Spain
Paquito
no se yeah my mom's a Spanish teacher
he's a Argentine yeah but I don't know I
mean I know it's me it's the Argentine
and his mom's a Spanish teacher so then
he should have known but then he sucks
at learning yeah do I need skills sure
I've ever done off the record with you
or you explain who you are actually he
just he's been he's been here for like
ever
yeah what do you do this plan who you
[ __ ] you is dog mm-hmm
a Mike I am hi Mike I did a 15-minute
stare down with a buzz and we became
besties
how did you meet these two unscrupulous
fools so uh I work in the fitness
industry for like ten years he's strong
as [ __ ] all right not really does it
look like I'm not really not I open and
failed the gym by the age are like 19 so
I've been doing bad things
you mean like you opened up a gym and it
failed already at 19 yeah oh just didn't
want to go workout in there they didn't
like yeah it wasn't like part of a
brigade so I felt I mean but even
opening one it's pretty legit how long
did it open for two years that's not bad
was it in California
yeah I live in Sacramento see most
people don't most businesses don't make
it past the first year but I've heard if
you make it past the first you you go
forever and I didn't do don't go for
double failures like 19 so like yeah
what did you know I'm not that smart now
f-word yeah you know what you succeeded
at finding a way that didn't work yeah I
do that good did you learn anything
no not yet yeah you learn like business
partners who to work with and who not to
and that's what so I worked in the
fitness industry I I did some social
media marketing and just marketing a
general fitness company and Bart was one
of the first people I reached out to
with the product that I was working with
and then I think I did a seminar on how
to lift weights at Barbara Brigade
before it opened the newest location
yeah they fed me McDonald took your
business yeah damn so Bart just stole
your idea Chinese dude yeah NGO is not
really involved with anything's true see
Bart stole the idea and geo made it
happen
probably barbell but grade whenever I
try to give her credit for it though so
she's very she's very wishy-washy yeah
what is it are you are you a partner or
what are you I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up
okay and then that side and then I think
I think I stayed at your house maybe
almost for like two or three weeks after
that and then now I just moved in and
then knows it you moved into their house
not really but whatever I'm done well
that's great yeah so good friends proud
or not do you sleep in the pantry it's
really big no but my closets freakin
huge
that's bigger than my bedroom yeah you
see their bedroom it's two bedrooms and
it was three bedrooms cuz if you count
the closet
it's two bedrooms in one bedroom and
then another bedroom for the closet huh
I landed late lesson their bedroom is
the size of my house yeah no but not
even kidding it looks like a living room
and a bedroom and in the closet looks
like another bedroom I was angry at the
pictures because they didn't tell me a
real description of what it was when I
went inside the house I was like oh the
pictures lied it's much bigger in person
yeah they're Island in their kitchen is
like a continent [ __ ] conversation
about silent might water
My Kitchen it always comes back to you
and I thought he was saying that y'all
had a goddamn island like my face was
like excuse I did see an island for sale
for like 500k there's some cheap I think
that's going I heard they're buying an
Iowa State like one of the worst
investments you could do because then
you have to purify the water you have to
set up electing there yes there's
infrastructure what yeah utilities costs
like way more I'm trying to get like a
cheap it's like a pool it's cost more
maintenance that it's not worth it I
heard but if there's an island with a
plug right and on this plug is like
17,000 USB ports so we could just plug
all our [ __ ] that's a lot of us people
another one with a plug that has like 20
gasps okay can you grow food oh yeah you
know it's just sad electricity
it's sad groan deliver [ __ ] post I just
want to get away from Bart so I need my
Island okay bye now you I want to see
you reality I'll hide in your closet and
that's then he'll never find you I want
to see like a reality show where some
rich person puts 10 people on an island
but just gives them a couple of tools
and they'll be like alright survivor
money to your family but you got to get
this island started like I'm trying to
watch that [ __ ] is that what survivor is
no they want a million dollars
oh they just win a million dollars yeah
no I want them to live on the island for
ten years I know I know what you're
talking about
no it's a North Korean version of that
it's called I Linda and what they do is
the it's like so here's like it's kind
of like that Battle Royale but then it's
like whoever survives your family won't
die I like the race yeah that'll make me
work yeah yeah dude would you survive a
battle royale or hunger no not coming
out you get a team I think I would lose
a teammate do you what I'll do up your
ass let me you look me right in my
eyeball kill me it's you or my family
you're dead
yeah well I would want to kill myself
first that's why I said that cuz I don't
even want to let someone else have the
privilege of taking my life
dude like mine and I'd be like okay
maybe I'd stay alive for you but then I
think for me your dad and who the other
people I'm competing against like let's
say she is in it too
let's say all of you guys were in it
yeah I'll go I'll soul eat the berries
although we're not gonna kill each other
that we're gonna overtake this
government what that's what they did
later there's all Hunger Games boilers I
[ __ ] up because I was ready to kill I
was like first nah oh my god Battle
Royale let's do this right now who dies
first in ordered Nikki dies first
I'll survive the longest where they'll
picking on you oh are you just like I
said I would kill myself for yeah I know
oh I want to deal with that I don't want
to deal with it I don't want to deal
with me trusting someone and getting
heartbroken there and Tipper get into a
double suicide all the emotional [ __ ]
that would kill me first and then I
would just rather okay you were gonna do
that then can we work together at least
and you could be a distraction attached
to people and if they turn on me cuz
that happened throughout my whole life I
just would it couldn't deal so they do
it again so if you're gonna sell so if
you could self-sacrifice we should use
that Vantage of that like as a
distraction yeah and while you do that
then everyone gets away and then takes
over the guard and Mickey was like
really dramatic
thanks to Nikki I'll be a martyr yeah
you'll be like Nikki's sacrifice herself
so we could escape and take over game D
but never let it have sad that she
wouldn't let it happen Stevie will be
like no I'll sacrifice myself no we like
you Steve yeah it's diva survivor kill
you what if they're like that they're so
like so if all of us go no we're all
gonna sacrifice ourselves and then they
they can't even do anything I feel like
a lot of la people wouldn't survive hell
no
I wouldn't survive at all if there was a
draught I thought you really thought
dude
look here's I'm saying Nikki dies first
then Bart only no way I'm drafted Martin
if I get to me if I get a teammate I'm
drafting Bart me I would not die with
military experience Dennis Bob are no
Bart gets too hungry so that's his
script I know we'd find a way bugs could
be on his team I'm on his team a don't
like you know he doesn't want to be on
your team he wants to survive okay you
want to live you want to die you want to
look at me no not not in eighth grade I
did a class trip I went to a really
weird school - there's another fact
about me like a weird art school where
like you guys went to the music calling
it weird not us yeah no no it is weird
okay what is the school called Waldorf
Waldorf salad yeah - the Walden school
no that's a collective like Montessori
Oh
Montessori color beside the point well I
went down I went down a river for seven
days just a backpack in the canal well
that was a school camping trip that was
are those our graduation trip you guys
want to like Six Flags or some [ __ ] yes
like that wasn't that a hole I
absolutely hated it but I can survive
did you have to like sharpen a stick in
like spear yes and Ethan both sides and
you start running around like this and
[ __ ] that crazy dude that sounds fun no
shell [ __ ] do know you'd I did I
would not you could not even you think
I'm pretty
go do it do it I don't need to do it oh
if we killed Bose we could survive up my
butt for a long time I'm just saying I
would die I would I would die third
probably my heart after bar you think
you would have the whole bar got the
whole world Lee
you brought your ass just like [ __ ]
attract so much attention they be like
it's earnest you try to hide it's all
sticking out everything ground is
rattling no because I would animal
slaughter a started chasing after you
[ __ ] ir baboon was like a big red but
really hide and then like when I think
that like when I heard that Simon like
Berber like only three people are left
I'd come out like yeah I can take on
three people and then [ __ ] die stop
waiting they're like looking at you from
the [ __ ] head you got a gun my spear
I mean you can't make [ __ ] dude just
gonna sit there cry with a [ __ ] stick
in it stone me yeah I don't cry okay
tough guy I'm gonna seduce the guard and
I'm gonna get away what guard he's
trying to survive - no there's a guard
there's gotta be a gate yeah find a gate
and seduce the guard you're in alright I
mean like I'm always the person that
drops this well I've read the comments I
got say you guys got tell us in comments
who survives JK news battle royale and
why it's why I take myself out I don't
like this whole like favourite war I
don't like it I'm gonna take my own
stuff out you can't even vote for me not
if you wanted to I'm not gonna survive
I'm not I already killed myself you know
Nicky to the Mart your name don't you -
sure it's done - yeah if I [ __ ] shoot
Bert right now why would you shoot me
I'm gonna boys everyone get these
[ __ ] guns we dropped out of the sky
[ __ ] I run into the house and I pick up
the his [ __ ] have you got eggs
over refrigerator that's not the Hunger
Games the hardest part to me about
survivors that they don't get coffee
like when I watch that show I'm like
they don't get coffee in the morning I'm
out like I'm out immediately
wait survivor no I know people that have
been on it but they're in the tropics
Bear Grylls or whatever that's who's
fake yeah that's faith he was like
literally in the hotel yeah yeah well
he's not just show
survival technique he's actually
formerly British Special Forces yeah
yeah that's just when they're shooting
it yeah he's not camping he's doing all
that stuff and then later he goes into
the but he doesn't say that
well he's not staying there for like a
show yeah but no what's his name does it
uh Survivorman no he's a old guy what
about man vs. wild that's what I'm
talking about that's bear oh oh that's
bear Joseph but there's like an old guy
that does it for real
yeah if you like camp out there he's
just a GoPro yeah yeah GoPro there's
actually like people on YouTube that
just go out and they'll be like 30 days
in the for it that's dope yeah do you
think that they do actually do 30 I
think you people can for sure that'd be
more connected to a world in nature I
was already familiar know where you from
Virginia where are you from
Sekhmet you guys flirty you guys on a
first date right we just did we just did
it connect you ever liked killing each
other and you're like there on the first
day I'm from Santa Barbara
that's maybe word no it's not it's a
beach town everyone's stone Ellie it was
on so it's different it's a different
vibe well there's no drugs
oh very sober so so like Santa Barbara
everyone likes it seems like a STONER
because most people are everyone thinks
I'm uh still in our because I just have
Santa Barbara in me I don't even smoke
pot but you gotta feel like they're fake
stoners you know where the real stoners
are saying if I was on hundred grams I
would you would see the Santa Barbara at
me it'd be like yo everybody just stop
fighting I'll kill myself hey let's just
start like I can't do that stoners from
like Shasta like those people are gonna
survive mmm like those cruelty people
they're living yeah that like the skin
like animals dance around yeah yeah yeah
those guys are survivors not saying a
barbara stoners that's like Matthew
McConaughey with a surfboard why are
ones yeah do you think Steve would
survive as a survivor
he's a survival mentality person
survival he also hates camping
he hates camping so I don't know if he
would survive but he would definitely do
his damnedest to survive Steve would
like you know that movies were like one
person in the couple dies and the other
person from the couple says no take me
to like I feel like oh that's Steve yeah
no it's you would be in denial that I
would be dying you'd be like no you're
not allowed to die
dammit back when you got your own back
yeah exactly he's told me that before
sunlight nah baby if there's an
apocalypse just [ __ ] shoot me he's
like I'm not gonna do it like imma imma
shoot myself then I got you you're not
gonna be able to pull the trigger with
the gun this way and he's sticking his
finger behind the trigger and he's
fighting this way I don't know what
would what would Gio do if Bart died in
the in the disco party dude you think
you'll cry oh oh wait is this a berry
now no I'm gonna turn against all of you
gajeel would be like this dude I did not
lead up for one bit because one time in
Gio and I are hanging out she was like I
don't put our secrets all blessed oh
yeah though she was like I don't like to
be alone and she was wait you were like
but I don't like hanging out with people
only bard yeah the only person I could
tolerate forever yeah yeah I was like
that was like the first time I was like
oh she does like him my [ __ ] secret I
can't believe he likes bar no no weird
cuz I've never I'm not with you guys so
much now and I've never seen you guys
like I never seen
[Applause]
dude I feel like even when I watch the
video I'm gonna look away yeah you're
turning away an actor kiss the tongue
didn't go inside the mouth oh it was
like this you rejected it's getting hard
now not handle that at all
what PDA oh well PDA is rough for me I
don't think that's PDA I think that's a
little beyond that's [ __ ] around is
it yeah well I don't know what the term
I throw at it but like PDAs and that
just like holding hands I guess so
public kissing you ever like a tongue
down the throat like mouth rape isn't
what is that porn you think that's porn
no what did you go out then advanced PDA
yeah that's like like loving that's PDL
this is affection less is PDL lust oh
yeah I don't know what draws the line
for PDA any part it pulls if a butt
comes out if a tongue comes out no tip
of dick just the tip even I don't care
that's illegal right yeah so that's
beyond - yeah okay what if we're
watching a movie there's a couple in
front of you and then they're just
making out going ham and you can just
hear it all it's Lila oh I mean that's
me and Steve that's where you feel
attacked right now and you're eating
with your friends and then they're
sitting next to each other and you hear
that's fine as long as you can't see it
I'm eating like it's not a big deal and
then he goes oh I feel a technician have
you jerk steve-o up under the dinner
table before we're all eating sushi
sushi is great Oh
Jager Bomb Mickey tries to cover it's
interesting because I can't imagine you
guys like Bart just put his arm around
her I can't oh my god I just heard it I
heard it this video yeah but like
meanwhile I can literally hear Mickey
kissing Steve and I've never seen it
before it's just like the way I guess
you guys act uh-huh and put it out there
who put that vibe out yeah I hate PDA I
love my husband
[Music]
[Music]